il est bien ce matin moi j'en fais du
trimaran quand je pars en vacances avec
ma femme et mes enfants sur le mien vous
pourrez pas venir avec votre femme et
vos enfants avec grand regret ouais
c'est vrai bateau de course
ouais et des paquets de mer à 40 noeuds
armée obligatoire tout le temps que le
problème à ces vitesses là pour le temps
que le bateau fasse demi tour s'il est à
30 noeuds le sanglot votre fasse
demi-tour sens de voilure pour affronter
levante il a 39 c'est qu'on y est déjà
du vent qu'on récupère l'homme
on est 20 minutes si on est à 30 noeuds
en vingt minutes on est déjà rendu à 18
km de lui une tête d'homme à 18 km c'est
dur à voir vous rester à bord alors 72
jours attachée avec cas ce pas 72 jours
à ça fait du bien mais ce que les
mascaras elle est aussi mcgill 62 jours
attachée
je suis retrouvé avec quatre saisons qui
vous crie dessus en costume de bourreau
voilà sans alcool et en mangeant des
sucres lents comme drucker il ya des
[ __ ] dans la cale ou pas du tout rien
pas de femmes à bord non alors quand on
vous demande pourquoi vous repartez vous
dites parce que j'ai déjà le record pour
y est resté à terre vous dites pourquoi
faire l'amour alors qu'on l'a déjà fait
ces mêmes gens la question idiote quoi
mais si os la réponse est cohérente plus
ce bateau est née de l'expérience de la
réflexion et du travail donc laisser
aller avec ce bateau là aujourd'hui au
tour du monde pour moi c'est un bonheur
un second c'est un bonheur presque grâce
comme tous les bruits environnants sont
brégier donc au plomb va vous suivre ici
à toutes les semaines on donnera de
nouvelles et tout ça on pourra vous
appeler au téléphone non non moi je peux
appeler mais on peux pas me plaindre on
nous appelait fort envoyé un telex
d'abord il est un télex sa cagnotte et
vous le lisez vous avez le temps de le
relire on peut pas m'appeler sinon je
vais me transformer en scandale je vous
appellerai vous appellerai si vous êtes
gentils avec dakar alors donc maintenant
olivier avec ce geronimo vous allez vous
lancer dans toutes les grandes courses
qui vont arriver et je parle de la robe
dorée
j'aime ça
après le tour du monde on descend sur
l'australie ont fait un peu à la coop
américains ont fait le tour de
l'australien on remonte sur en compte
pour faire en kong londres après on
rentre quand l'on danse un ordre de
retour en europe et ça fera dans 18 mois
à peu près 1 pour me rassurer new york
pour new york san francisco après on
sera san francisco a while c'est
vachement bien
c'est parti pour cinq ans là oui
j'aimerais bien plus mais après je vais
peut-être trop vieux mais c'est le merci
mais si c'est la vie de la ville peut
pas avoir une plus belle vie que ça nous
donnerait 100 millions de dollars pour
arrêter de faire ce que je fais je riais
par peut même monter adoua gros au
double au triple discute toujours pas
est ce que toi tu penses que tu mourras
dans ton lit ou sur un bateau je suis
pas pressé de coûts que ça soit ça sera
pas une bonne nouvelle pour moi
maintenant que m'en fous aux prières et
mes jeux je pense que j'ai pas envie de
mourir dans les budgets pas peur non
plus je vais demander si comme les
comédiens grand comédien qui souhaitent
mourir sur scène je vais demander si les
grands marins soit à mourir dans
l'accident le non non non moi je veux
pas mourir du tout on va parler de la
vie alors
or d'avoir ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que kersauson ça vient de care saxons
c'est un nom de guerriers envahisseurs
est sûr est que vous avez une âme
guerrière un peu comme ça c'est assez
inédit terre d'une certaine façon oui
d'après ce que j'ai compris de n'être
pas trop délicat pierre taxons alors
vous êtes issu d'une famille catholique
conservatrice ski pour des bretons
étaient assez normal 25 ans en bretagne
du coma voilà alors vos ancêtres avaient
acheté louis saez le manoir de keroual
et pourquoi vous l'avez plus aujourd'hui
ça appartient à la ville de brest ce
j'en ai un autre à côté quai mieux avant
plus partie une autre question juste une
queue alors bon mais il faut savoir que
les kersauson ont participé très
activement à l'histoire de france
il y avait un bien avant louis saez y
avait un quart sauzon qui dirigeait la
flotte qui emmenait saint louis aux
croisades robert de kersauson à sa
statue au cap
parce qu'il s'était engagé dans la
guerre des boers par la haine de
l'angleterre
- il aimait pas les anglais ils habitent
à los angeles il est rentré de los
angeles et s'est installé en afrique du
sud pour pour taper de l'anglais frappé
de l'anglais voilà et votre nom exact
c'est kersauson de penan bref voilà
exactement
alors cette septième d'une famille de
huit enfants rachitiques jusqu'à l'âge
de 10 ans à cause des privations de
guerre alors c'est vrai quand on voit
maintenant on se demande vous êtes bien
bien rattrapé ce qui est faible et
souvent mal hein devrait alors tout
jeune vous êtes déjà en décalage avec
votre milieu familial problèmes à
l'école nous fêtons ce collège religieux
ce qui est quand même beaucoup à vannes
par exemple c'est resté douze jours
1 alors où j'habitais pas en fait vous
réfugier dans le silence dans
l'indifférence qui est beaucoup plus
généralement évidemment pour les curés
qui vous qui vous surveille vous
réfugier dans le silence vous évader
dans le rêve dans la lecture entre 11 et
17 ans vous lisez un livre par jour
et si vous arrivez au bac et là vous
dites quand je suis à moba que j'avais
payé mon tribut au corps social et vous
jurer de ne plus jamais faire que ce qui
vous plaît oui vous avez jamais été en
fait quand même y aller en fac il y
avait le prof d'économie qui a le droit
mais il avait des chaussures à semelles
à l'époque un costume pas tout à fait
neuf elle mais qui attendent
n'expliquait l'économie je me disais à
100 c'est une arnaque totale
si la cour privée s'il a compris
l'économie doit pas être là je vais
laisser mes bouquins ouvert je suis
partie en moins mauvais de ce truc
alors voilà donc là vous découvrez la
mer c'est vrai que j'ai commencé à
barrer à la trinité sur mer sur le
cambronne de jean marie le pen louis xi
avait il y avait à l'époque il y avait
très peu de bateaux à la trinité sur mer
et j'adorais ce bateau non j'ai commencé
un avis ne lie avec tout ce qui traînait
l'épreuve
moi j'ai fait tous les bateaux de la
trinité sur mer et même parfois le soir
on commence avec les propriétaires
étaient à paris on ne rompt les anglais
pour aller se promener ce qui
aujourd'hui ont cela nous emmènera
directement en prison mais bon le pen
comment il était à l'époque assez sympa
en plus était à l'époque où il ya doute
il a fait la guerre d'algérie se
finissait moi j'avais affaire qui avait
fait la guerre d'algérie les nos aînés
au sens large du terme n'a été on avait
eu des morts
jerry d'un des départs entre le côté à
l'époque
l'ancien baroudeur qui n'était l'ancien
légionnaire le rendait pas déplaisant
qui s'était peint cette élection n'ont
pas le profil du mec s'est tenue à
l'époque c'était un mec uniquement
révolte est sympa c'est que c'est ce que
dit claude chabrol c'est quand les
ingénieurs les gens institut la révolte
qui deviennent au dieu ce qui est à caen
sadien
un système de marketing dans le sait
quelqu'un qui crie parce qu'il n'est pas
d'accord elle son entourage c'est
toujours émouvant trouve que quels
qu'ils soient alors donc après ça c'est
la mer pour toujours à vous dit si je
n'avais pas été marin j'aurais été marin
voilà moi j'ai cotisé sur le sur l'eau
tous les jours même si on appareils pavé
geronimo si on a pas et pas avec
alchimiste moi je prends un zodiac je me
promenais sur le jeu chaque journée j'y
prends un bonheur alors que dans les
autres métiers
il ya des moments géniaux quand vous
êtes avec tabarly que vous découvrez le
soleil de minuit pendant le solstice
d'été
voilà le soleil qui descend vers
l'horizon comme ça qu'ils tangente
l'horizon qui revient sans c'est génial
parfois le soleil donc refuse de se
coucher parfois c'est vous car là on a
parlé du quart sauzon de mer mais aussi
le kersauson des villes alors si jacques
martin vous avez rencontré à bora bora
ouais je passais avec un moteur à bora
bora lui il était là bas avec une
histoire triste et je sais pas j'ai
rencontré chez même pas qui c'était ce
que j'écoutais pas la radio j'ai jamais
écouté la région de ma vie et en
polynésie il avait trouvé assez drôle
c'est comme ça lui donne du copain avec
lui est alors celui qui l'a ouvert ce
quoi c'est autour de 73 les portes de
l'epr de castel est parti depuis 69 et
c'est lui qui m'a trouvé un job que
cache-t-elle rôle de son bateau donc
j'ai commencé à travailler sur le bateau
de castel tentatives
et puis a commencé un mario si oui alors
un an plus tard
vous décrochez votre premier grand
sponsor critères elle devenait skipper à
votre tour
et puis jacques martin vous présente à
bouvard il a eu beaucoup d'importance
pour vous jacques martin finalement
énorme
ouais moi j'ai connu un individu d'une
grande culture d'une grande intelligence
et d'une drôlerie extraordinaire je vais
le voir en ce moment téléphone autant
vraiment il va moyen très difficile de
toujours difficile de reparler à la des
gens qui est qu que la vie pour les
avants médicale à plus ou moins exclu
d'un monde où il régnait
mais j'adore ce type moi je trouve ça
c'est un grand personnage si nous
regarde nous regarde
resterait donc vous entrez aux grosses
têtes au début alors vous tourner le dos
au public par timidité c'est énorme ça
on fait de la à lyon ce pas la
télévision
rien que des places il ya c'est un
travail donc autant rester concentré que
les gens avec qui on travaille
j'ai pas de gros moyens de concentration
alors à une fois que vous prenez bien
soin de répéter que tout ça c'est pour
gagner votre vie pour gagner de quoi
naviguer et vous avez même déclaré je
fais cette émission comme je conduirai
un camion poubelle qui signifie deux
choses la première c'est que j'ai pas
dis respect pour le fait de courir à
camions pouvaient est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai fait que je suis aux états unis
et ensuite c'est que le le le
aucun travail n'est une onde donc moi je
n'ai jamais pris de plaisir à le faire
parfois parce qu'on y avait de bons
copains ou qu'on travaillait que joe
rien ou sébastien où le luron martin on
s'est vraiment marrer mais le sa main
pour la moitié de ce que je touchais
s'il allait accepter que je vienne
passera alors là vous développez dans
les grosses têtes votre personnage
d'ours mal léché qui fait de vous une
star en fait une star des médias
un ours mal léché avec un caractère de
cochon et vous dites souvent vers le
premier contact me dérange toujours
ouais hein avec les jambes ça c'est un
peu faux je vois les gens trois fois
pour commencer elle à l'aise avec eux
c'est le troisième le premier contact me
gêne toujours oui c'est la 3 4e fois je
vous vois ça va bien la marne mais c'est
vrai que la culture bretonne c'est pas
très affectif ya pas beaucoup de
familiarité il a pas du tout il ya un
énorme quant à soi à un énorme
on ne communique pas
ni ses émotions et on ne parle pas il ya
une vraie culture c'est qu'on ne parle
pas ne commande pas ou ne se plaint pas
ça n'a pas que des qualités fallait
qualité je crois que ça fait aussi
perdre beaucoup de choses sortent
émotionnel réels qui sont donc ils sont
devant nous et que et dont ne profitent
pas [ __ ] de savoir les utiliser c'est
un peu triste aussi a changé aussi c'est
fait des progrès en ce moment je te
ferai je te brise rien je vais le
rappeler
on est huit amis nos vestiaires on
arrive à la fiche 69 vous connaissez le
principe
c'est vous qui me posait une question
vous êtes heureux
ouais ça va salut du temps puisque je
pensais ça va alors oui c'est vrai que
vous êtes un ours mal léché là la mère
de votre fils dit pour parler avec toi
il faut prendre rendez vous ouais ouais
parce que la plupart du temps ces
tailleurs quoi comme gil soit en train
de lire un livre a peu joué
oui bah oui j'ai pas eu des qualités en
fait j'aime bien sûr vous me parlez dit
demain 10h ce que je peux parler avec
toi les oui demain 10 heures comme ça je
me prépare psychologiquement mais
connaissant mes semelles maintenant
comme je peux écouter sinon si on part
je voulais pas écouté ou je pense pas
autre chose vous ça va me déranger ce
que je suis en train de penser à autre
chose
alors j'ai eu un enfant s'appelle arthur
avec la comédienne caroline verbe qui
est l'arrière petite fille de jules
verne saint saëns et ça c'était voulu ou
c'est un hasard ben non j'ai pas cherché
cherche arrière petite fille de grands
écrivains pour reprocher qu'on dit est
absolument
je fais est réservée aux membres ça m'a
vite gonflé j'ai toujours pensé que non
mais c'est vrai les gens que l'amour
passionné des tarbes à l'embl j'ai
jamais mis un disque de ma vie j'écoute
pas de musique je m'en passe
complètement et mes oreilles me servent
à écouter ou dans les bois ou sur la mer
donc j'ai pas accès à ça je n'accepte ça
me gêne pas bon l'amour il ya la partie
romantique m'a assez vite échappé est
resté l'autre la partie fonctionnelle
donc le simulacre de la reproduction m'a
toujours intéressé énormément je vais
vous le sexe on vous dit que c'est le
seul moment où on échapper c'est un
moment d'absolu alors que le le
j'ai bien aimé la surproduction en
elle-même jamais vraiment passionné vous
avez été souvent quitter
c
et
pourquoi ton des chèques au nom
m'échappe autant d'échecs s'étaient
quittés au moins deux trois fois dans ma
vie mais à chaque fois je partais en
l'air aussi dans quelques mois je
pratique est une lâcheté en exercice et
le fait que quand vous savez que vous
allez partir vous n'avez pas besoin de
recoller les bouts depuis l'hôtel
rapport maintenant je suis assez
formidable aussi de se dire bon à temps
elle me gonfle
la monf aussi mais toute façon dans 15
jours je suis parti donc c'est pas la
peine d'insister je vais de toute façon
ne faire aucun effort
c'est à fait assez délicieux c'est
dégueulasse mais c'est délicieux et jeu
c'est dégueulasse en fait c'est un faux
misogyne suite le paradis terrestre
c'était quand m arriva est long faire
c'est quand adam ont pris l'habitude oui
je crois oui je pense que ça en fait
vous supportez pas c'est la routine
non mais je pense qu'il le rapport avec
il faut que toujours considéré que le
fin moi c'est ce que j'ai cru avoir
compris ce qui ne l'est pas d'une grande
intelligence une grande puissance
rassurez vous j'ai toujours pensé qu' il
fallait prendre la magie de l'autre où
elle passait dans son entité et surtout
pas penser que cette magie allait durer